et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
françois-xavier bellamy bonjour bonjour
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous député
européen membre des républicains on est
ensemble pendant 20 minutes quand on
intervient en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale et ce matin on a
le plaisir d'accueillir marcelo et
serait bonjour marne
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous grand
reporter au service politique politique
du parisien aujourd'hui en france merci
marcelo d'être là on commence évidemment
françois-xavier bellamy par nicolas
sarkozy qui a donc été reconnu coupable
hier en première instance condamné à
trois ans de prison dont un ferme pour
corruption et trafic d'influencé dans l'
affaire dite des écoutes c'est une
première pour un ancien président de la
république que pensez vous de ce
jugement
écoutez moi je suis très préoccupé de ce
jugement et de ce qu'il traduit on parle
beaucoup aujourd'hui sur la scène
européenne de la question de l'état de
droit et je crois que nous avons
probablement des questions à nous poser
sur la manière dont l'état de droit
fonctionne en france aujourd'hui je ne
dirais pas cela de n'importe quel
jugement concernant un responsable
politique de droite ou bien nicolas
sarkozy je parle ici de ce jugement pour
avoir suivi
grâce à vos confrères qui ont écouté
l'audience les débats qui s'y sont
tenues il apparaît que au terme de ces
débats l'accusation est en réalité
extrêmement fragile la vérité c'est
qu'on reproche à nicolas sarkozy un coup
de pouce qu'il n'a pas donnés au
bénéfice d'un candidat qui n'a pas
candidaté en échange d'un service qu'il
n'a pas reçues et tout cela a été
démontré
le fait que ce coup de pouce est été
envisagé dans une conversation
téléphonique entre un client et son
avocat qui est aujourd'hui la seule
matière qui fondent ce jugement et la
matière de cette condamnation
extrêmement grave et je crois que nous
avons ici l'occasion d'un soupçon envers
la justice qui est une très mauvaise
nouvelle pour notre vie politique
aujourd'hui je le vois très bien
malheureusement le travail de l'exécutif
est très souvent discréditer la parole
des parlementaires est très souvent
discréditer nous n'avons rien à gagner
au fait que les français puissent
regarder la justice comme étant elle
aussi instrumentaliser ou
instrumentalisable au service d'une
stratégie politique je crois que c'est
grave et c'est d'autant plus grave
encore une fois que
nous vivons cette montée de la défiance
moi je ne crois pas qu'il faille entrer
dans une sorte de al ahly contre le
gouvernement des juges eux dans cette
espèce de spirale démagogie qui consiste
à mettre en accusation la justice mais
il faut que la justice dans ce cas soit
incontestable et ici elle me laisse plus
velenje
il y aura un appel ce sont des juges
indépendants qui ont rendu leur décision
hier on est donc dans un signe dans un
état de droit normal et j'espère qu'ils
sont indépendants
j'espère lors de son j'espère qu'ils
sont indépendants de toute pression
politique j'espère qu'ils sont
indépendants de toute stratégie
indépendants y compris des pressions qui
peuvent s'exercer de l'intérieur de
l'appareil judiciaire
vous n'êtes pas sans savoir que
aujourd'hui il ya un vrai sujet avec le
parquet national financier alors ou des
vhu dépression animalière qui a qui a
rendu son verdict bien sûr mais qui
n'est pas indépendant justement de tous
les actes d' enquêtes qui ont été opérés
par le parquet national financier au
préalable nous ne sommes pas là encore
sans ignorer que ce jugement est le
résultat d'une procédure hautement
discutable y compris du point de vue de
la cour européenne des droits de l'homme
parce qu'on s'est servi encore une fois
d'écouter d'abord d' écoute on parle ici
des coups tu as filets dérivants c'est à
dire qu'on a écouté pendant des mois 24
heures sur 24 une personnalité avec
l'idée de trouver la preuve d'une
infraction qui n'a pas été établie dans
une affaire pour laquelle il a été
relaxé
et cela a donné l'occasion d'ouvrir une
autre enquête pour une autre infraction
supposer c'est tout cela et encore une
fois hautement discutable tout cela est
même contraire à des arrêts qui ont été
rendus par la cour européenne des droits
de l'homme et je le redis il y a là des
conséquences qui doivent toucher tous
les français quoi qu'on pense de nicolas
sarkozy quoi qu'on pense de sa politique
passée de sa personnalité il y a quelque
chose qui doit tous nous inquiéter
maître henri leclerc qui n'est pas
spécifiquement un avocat de droite qui
est même engagé à gauche est venu
témoigner à l'audience en disant la
gravité de ce qui était en train de se
jouer
lorsque des avocats pénalistes sont
maintenant obligés de dire à leurs
clients nous ne pouvons pas parler par
téléphone je ne sais pas si je suis
écouté c'est c'est quand même des
questions qu'en démocratie on ne devrait
pas avoir à se poser et qu'il est
important
d'hier est un mouvement politique le
jugement d'hier en tous les cas il
paraît vraiment je le dis sans être un
spécialiste de la justice je le dis sans
prétendre exercer une influence sur le
processus judiciaire mais comme un
citoyen et comme un citoyen français qui
a non seulement le droit mais le devoir
de s'intéresser à la manière dont la
justice est rendue en son nom on nous
dit il faut pas commenter des décisions
de justice mais je vois pas d'où vient
cette injonction
il est nécessaire de commenter des
décisions de justice on commente les
actes du pouvoir législatif
on commente les actes du pouvoir
exécutif on a aussi le droit et le
devoir de s'inquiéter de la manière dont
est rendu la justice elle est rendue en
notre nom
or comme un citoyen qui a suivi ces
débats je m'inquiète d'un décision qui
semble encore une fois ci peut fonder si
mal fondée avec des conséquences aussi
graves sur le plan politique si on
élargit un petit peu quelles
conséquences ça va avoir selon vous pour
la présidentielle est ce que vous a
terni pas quelque part un peu l'image
des républicains évidemment que ça ne
peut pas ne pas avoir de conséquence ça
ça aura des conséquences je sais pas si
ça va ternir l'image des républicains
d'une certaine manière ça n'est même pas
ce qui est le plus grave dans cette
affaire le plus grave encore une fois
c'est peut-être que ça finisse par
ternir l'image de la justice elle-même
et moi c'est ça qui me préoccupe le plus
on a eu cette interférence incroyable
d'un calendrier judiciaire dans
l'accélération était totalement inédite
au moment de la sphère fillon en 2017
pendant l'élection présidentielle
on a maintenant de nouveau entré avec
fracas de la justice dans un moment
politique très singulier pour la france
qui est la préparation de la prochaine
élection présidentielle
ce serait encore une fois nécessaire et
légitime si la décision était vraiment
mûri fondé incontestable indiscutable le
moins qu'on puisse dire c'est qu'elle ne
l'est pas et moi c'est ça qui encore une
fois m'inquiète profondément je ne veux
pas rentrer dans une situation dans
laquelle on assisterait à une sorte de
guerre de la défiance entre le politique
et
le judiciaire parce que personne n'a
rien à gagner à cette situation et je
crois qu'il est absolument fondamental
de ce fait que au moins nous puissions
reconnaître que l'appel vous l'avez dit
qui a été prononcée évidemment suspensif
de l'appel par définition invalides le
jugement de première instance en attente
d'un nouveau jugement et que par
conséquent la présomption d'innocence
doit être pleinement reconnue à nicolas
sarkozy et aux autres prévenus de ce
point de vue là cela permet au moins je
crois si nous respectons ces principes
d' aborder l'élection présidentielle
avec plus de transparence et de liberté
on va parler d'un autre sujet
françois-xavier bellamy vous avez été
chargé en février 2020 d'une mission sur
l'identité politique de la droite
européenne sur son avenir
vous allez rendre public aujourd'hui vos
travaux quels sont vos conclusions
nous avons mené ce travail parce que au
fond la droite en europe rencontrent des
difficultés fortes comme celle que la
droite connaît aujourd'hui en france de
vraies difficultés stratégique nous
avons eu il y a maintenant un peu plus
d'un an une une conversation de fond
avec tous les chefs de délégation
nationale de notre groupe au parlement
européen sur sur la question de
l'identité politique de la droite et est
au fond il est apparu que nous avions
besoin de faire ce travail de fond et le
groupe le président de notre groupe eut
le groupe m'ont confié la mission de
travailler à réécrire un texte fondateur
pour notre famille politique en europe
et je me suis attelé à cette tâche avec
des des collègues des élus de plusieurs
pays européens ça a été un travail
passionnant un travail de fond ce qui en
ressort à moi ma conviction profonde
c'est que la droite ne gagne rien à
renier ce qu'elle doit être
et qu'elle ne retrouvera la confiance
des électeurs que si elle est à la fois
fidèle à sa tradition politique à sa
tradition intellectuelle
je suis professeur de philosophie j'ai
aussi abordé cette question avec au fond
ce qu'on pourrait appeler une
philosophie politique de ce qui fait
l'identité de la droite mais avec en
même temps de l'imagination de la
créativité pour proposer des solutions à
la société de demain et c'est le
résultat de ce travail qui fait une
vingtaine de pages que nous avons
longuement mûri qui a été approuvé par
notre groupe parlementaire et qui va
être présentée effectivement aujourd'hui
à tous les partis politiques de droite
européenne
quelles sont les grandes lignes de votre
réflexion au fond nous avons voulu
construire notre travail sur l'idée de
la transmission ce qui définit la droite
c'est peut-être le fait qu'elle a le
sens du temps long c'est la nécessité
d'une forme de prudence devant les
grands équilibres qui font que le monde
est vivable que le monde est habitable
évidemment les grands équilibres de la
nature et de ce point de vue là la
droite doit se préoccuper d'écologie
elle doit être pionnière sur ces
questions mais aussi ses équilibres
culturels qui font la clé de la paix
civile dans une société
je crois que de ce point de vue là il
est fondamental que la droite soit le
parti qui en europe défendra par exemple
une politique éducative ambitieuse une
politique migratoire assez ferme pour
nous permettre de relever le défi de
l'intégration ce défi qui est partout
présent en europe
si nous voulons lutter contre le
séparatisme bien nous devons nous
préoccuper de cet équilibre culturelle
dans nos sociétés de lutter contre cette
insécurité culturel qui pointent
aujourd'hui en europe et qui menace de
diviser de déchirer profondément les
sociétés occidentales
ce sont des défis majeurs on a parfois
parlé de conservatisme ce terme gelé
bien souvent répété me paraît
insuffisant pour qualifier les la
difficulté que nous avons à relever il
s'agit pas seulement de conserver
il s'agit d'une certaine manière de
sauver ce qui doit l'être pour pouvoir
le transmettre aux générations qui
viennent dans un contexte de crise
globale
et c'est dans ce contexte là que notre
réflexion s'inscrivait alors l'union
européenne c'est très concret notamment
pour les frontaliers de moselle
aujourd'hui s'ils veulent rentrer en
allemagne ils ont besoin d'un test pcr
s c'est une décision quasiment
unilatérale de l'allemagne
comment on en est arrivé là vous êtes
député européen on en est arrivé là
parce que l'europe a eu du mal à faire
face à la crise sanitaire d'une manière
ordonnée d'une manière unie
effectivement aujourd'hui on ne peut que
regretter cette décision de l'allemagne
nous le partageons aussi au parlement
européen je crois que il est fondamental
de évidemment de faire face à cette
crise sanitaire avec la prudence et les
règles qu'elle impose en même temps il
est fondamental aussi que nos sociétés
puissent continuer de vivre de
travailler vous l'avez dit beaucoup de
travailleurs frontaliers aujourd'hui
sont empêchés d'une certaine manière de
pratiquer normalement leurs activités
professionnelles par c'est par ces
mesures qui s'imposent de manière
unilatérale et je crois que de ce point
de vue comme sur le reste des mesures
sanitaires que nous sommes en train de
connaître aujourd'hui il me semble que
nous n'avons pas réussi à trouver le bon
équilibre c'est clair entre la réponse
sur le front sanitaires et la nécessité
que la société puisse continuer à vivre
et que les gens puissent continuer à
travailler
est-ce que c'est pas quand même un coup
de canif dans la relation dans la
confiance franco-allemand de cette
décision
c'est encore une fois c'est le signe
d'une difficulté c'est évident de
l'union européenne a créé une réponse
qui soit équilibrée et qui soit
l'occasion de deux règles communes on a
aujourd'hui un espace schengen qui ne
fonctionnent plus parce que au fond les
pays européens prennent chacun leur
leurs décisions de manière assez
unilatérale c'est pas seulement
l'allemagne
moi je suis député européen je vais très
régulièrement à bruxelles la belgique
n'a cessé ces derniers mois
d'imposer des règles toujours
imprévisible toujours changeante et ça
rend très compliqué effectivement le
travail de ceux qui pour leur activité
professionnelle ont besoin de passer les
frontières
nous nous continuons de défendre le fait
que les états membres doivent garder la
souveraineté dans la maîtrise de leurs
frontières c'est clair je crois que
notamment sur la question migratoire
il n'y a aucune raison que nous
retirions définitivement aux états
membres la possibilité de maîtriser
leurs frontières et dans cette crise
cela est apparu de manière très claire
mais il faudrait que ça se fasse de
manière coordonnée et concertée et je le
répète je les dis depuis des mois mais
au fond il faudrait qu'on arrive à se
donner il compris sur le plan français
des indicateurs clairs pour fonder des
décisions
qu'ils soient ensuite du coup assez
cohérente pour pouvoir être appliquées
de manière simple et proportionnée
encore alors justement l'union
européenne envisage de travailler sur un
de mettre en place un passeport
vaccinale je suis vacciné je peux
voyager
vous êtes favorable il ya des états qui
le sont il ya des états qui ne sont pas
alors à ce stade il s'agit pas d'un
passeport vaccinale mais il s'agit d'un
certificat de vaccination
je pense qu'il est évidemment positif
que nous puissions avoir un document
unifié pour certifier de la vaccination
ça pour le coup ça ne me paraît pas du
tout un problème
l'idée d'un passeport vaccinale pour le
coup me paraît beaucoup plus difficile
parce que un passeport vaccinale ça
induit le fait que certaines activités
certains lieux serait interdit à des
gens qui n'ont pas été vaccinés ce qui
évidemment revient d'abord sur la
liberté de déterminer sa sa propre ses
propres choix à partir aussi de son de
son parcours
certaines personnes sont plus ou moins
sensibles à certains effets secondaires
peuvent être vulnérables donc il n'y a
pas de raison d'imposer la même règle à
tous d'une manière unilatérale que le
deuxième aspect qui est évidemment très
problématique c'est que dans un pays
comme la france nous sommes très à la
traîne sur la stratégie vaccinale
vous avez tout simplement beaucoup de
gens qui n'ont pas pu être vacciné et
donc l'idée qu'on va en même temps
imposer un passeport vaccinale qui va
conditionner votre possibilité d'accéder
à certains biens certains services
certains lieux cette idée là me paraît
profondément de la position de la france
de dire que c'est prématuré pour le
moment ce débat mais est ce que vous
pensez qu'on va forcément y venir au
niveau français au niveau européen non
je ne crois pas le principe d'un vaccin
c'est que à partir du moment où un
certain nombre de la population est
vaccinée ça produit une forme d'immunité
collective le sujet n'est pas seulement
l'immunité individuel ce serait d'autant
plus absurde que à ce stade il n'est pas
du tout prouvé que le vaccin évite
d'être contagieux vous pouvez être
vaccinés et être pourtant porteur du
virus ait contaminé quelqu'un donc
l'idée d'un passeport vaccinale in et
que au fond vous avez votre petit papier
et vous ne pouvez plus contaminés
personnes vous pouvez faire ce que vous
voulez aller partout cette idée là n'a
littéralement aucun sens ce qui poserait
bien sûr oui tout à fait celle-ci lui si
le vaccin a un sens c'est celui de
construire une forme d'immunité de
groupe et dans ce cas là effectivement
ce qui compte ce n'est pas le bac le
passeport individuel ce qui compte c'est
l'effet collectif comment vous comprenez
que aux états unis d
hardy le vaccin johnson & johnson qu'un
nouveau vaccin qui vient d'être
homologué sera distribué massivement et
qu'en france ça a été annoncé par le
gouvernement il faudra attendre au moins
la fin mars
vous êtes à la commission industrie
ainsi si je me trompe pas qu'est ce qui
se passe comment vous est ce qu'on est
trop prudent peut-être dans nos aux
homologations
d'abord c'est une bonne chose d'être
prudent le le problème n'est pas qu'on
soit trop prudent le problème c'est
qu'on soit trop lent le problème c'est
que nous n'avons pas les outils dont
disposent les états unis en matière par
exemple de politique industrielle
au delà de la question du vaccin c'est
intéressant de regarder comment se
structure nos politiques industrielles
en europe la politique industrielle a
été cette expression même a été un gros
mot pendant très longtemps parce que ce
qui comptait c'était la concurrence
libre et non faussée ce qui comptait
c'était de ce fait que les états se
retire de toute stratégie industrielle
et laisse faire le marché aux états unis
qui sont évidemment un pays plutôt
libérale ça n'a pas empêché que l'état
dans certains secteurs stratégiques se
dote d'outils qui sont extrêmement
structurée je pense par exemple au bar
d'à américain qui est une structure qui
permet d'homologuer rapidement des
médicaments qui permet de se donner des
stratégies forte en matière d'industrie
pharmaceutique
on sait très bien que dans certaines
industries sensibles la formation fait
partie on peut penser à la question de
la défense
on peut penser à d'autres industries qui
sont stratégiques il faut avoir une
politique affirmée et aujourd'hui nous
en manquons en france et il faut bien
reconnaître que malheureusement le
présent la république lui même est l'un
de ceux qui a été le plus le plus loin
dans cet abandon d'une politique
industrielle en cédant lorsqu'il était
ministre de l'économie et même depuis
qu'il était à l'elysée des secteurs
industriels absolument stratégique à des
acteurs étrangers et notamment à des
acteurs américains
je crois qu'il est temps de sortir de
cette naïveté c'est une urgence et c'est
la raison pour laquelle nous travaillons
au parlement européen a changé de
paradigme clients comme anna emmanuel
macron parce qu'il est plutôt sur une
position de retour à une souveraineté
nationale de retour une souveraineté
européenne dans les mots mais où sont
les faits dans les faits par exemple
la naïveté c'est le fait que une
entreprise comme photonis qui fabrique
des des outils de vision nocturne qui
sont aujourd'hui décisif pour nos forces
armées pourraient être cédés avec l'aval
de l'elysée à un acteur étranger
ça veut dire que nous perdrions un outil
décisif pour pouvoir garantir que nos
forces armées demain ils iront en
opération avec des matériels qui sont
propres à notre pays ou bien même tout
simplement à l'union européenne quand
les forces armées françaises sont partis
au mali elles n'ont pas pu utiliser
certains de leurs moyens parce que dans
ses moyens il y avait des composants
américains et que la loi américaine
impose qu'on demande l'autorisation aux
états unis d'amérique lorsqu'on veut
engager ses moyens qu'on a pourtant
acquis qu'on a acheté donc il a fallu
envoyer des documents aux américains
pour leur demander leur autorisation
sous deux mois
évidemment quand vous lancez une
opération militaire vous n'avez pas la
latitude de mener ce type de travail
donc il faut qu'on puisse reconstruire
une autonomie stratégique européenne et
je suis obligé de constater que ça se
fait contre le logiciel qui était celui
du président de la république il faut
quand même se souvenir faisait sa
campagne présidentielle en déclarant que
le protectionnisme c'est la guerre
l'idée qu' il faut protéger notre
industrie et est perçu par emmanuel
macron emmanuel macron le libéral
autoproclamé à mon avis plutôt le naïf
comme une forme de 2,2 de danger pour
l'équilibré mondial
françois-xavier bellamy justement dans
cette période n'y a pas de vaccin 100%
européen bon il ya des britanniques au
loin mais le premier ministre hongrois
lui a décidé de se faire vacciner par un
vaccin chinois
les slovaques ont choisi de commander du
vaccin russe est ce que finalement nous
français on a tort de tourner le dos à
ces vaccins qui ne viennent pas d'eux a
qui viennent de russie ou de chine par
exemple
encore une fois la première question à
se poser c'est comment se fait-il que
nous n'ayons pas de vaccin européen
aujourd'hui on le voit très bien la
stratégie vaccinale dans le monde est
devenu une occasion de diplomatie
d'influencé absolument redoutable
vous avez raison de parler de la chine
c'est un sujet majeur la chine est en
train littéralement d'acheter des
positions partout dans le monde
en vendant son vaccin à bas prix je
pense notamment à l'afrique avec
beaucoup de pays d'afrique ou du
moyen-orient la chine négocie le vaccin
contre eux sa prise de participation
dans des ports dans des
fra structures portuaires pour
développer son maillage à travers les
routes de la soie et étendre son réseau
il se passe à travers la question du
vaccin 1 transformation et un
basculement de l' équilibre géopolitique
et nous ne sommes pas à la hauteur de ce
rendez vous diplomatiques et
objectivement devenu une arme
diplomatique alors nous avons perdu
cette bataille c'est un fait la question
c'est comment gagneront nous les
batailles de demain comment nous donner
les moyens de reconstruire notre
autonomie stratégique et là encore on
reparlait de cette question de
l'industrie pharmaceutique sur la
question de la chine il m'arrive d'avoir
des points d'accord avec le gouvernement
hongrois notamment sur les questions
migratoires qui ont été un grand débat
européen et je pense que sur ces
questions là le gouvernement de viktor
orban a défendu une position ferme qui
aujourd'hui partagées par notre famille
politique
cela étant dit je crois qu'il y a de la
part sur ce point précis de la part de
la hongrie une forme là encore de
naïveté à l'égard de la stratégie
chinoise
moi je regrette aujourd'hui qu' on
puisse fermer les yeux sur ce qui est en
train de se jouer dans l'entrisme de la
chine
c'est le cas à travers les vaccins c'est
le cas aussi à travers par exemple cet
accord d'investissement entre l'union
européenne et la chine que pour ma part
je regarde avec énormément de
scepticisme et d'inquiétudes parce que
je crois que là encore nous faisons
preuve de naïveté quand il faudrait au
contraire se ressaisir et se donner les
moyens d'une réponse qui soit plus
offensive et plus stratégiques on va
terminer sur un autre sujet françois
xavier bellamy cessé selon ces violences
qui se multiplient on a vu ce
photojournaliste qui a été agressée à
reims qui se trouve entre la vie et la
mort on a vu ces rixes dans l'essonne la
semaine dernière ce jeune qui a été tué
par balles à bondy qu'est ce que ça dit
de notre société pour vous est ce que ça
dit si vous voulez c'est ce n'est pas
une collection de faits divers comme
comme le disait
un centre immolé devillers dans le
figaro récemment ce sont des faits de
civilisation c'est le signe que quelque
chose est en train de s'effondrer de ce
qui fait notre lien les uns aux autres
dans une forme de civilité partager la
violence qui a marqué ces faits a ceci
de très particulier qu'elle est très
souvent gratuite
c'est une violence absurdes anomique
dans le cas du jeune youri qui a été
passé à tabac sur la dalle de
beaugrenelle dans le 15e arrondissement
et dans le cas avait ému la france
entière
dans le cas de ces jeunes qui se sont
affrontés tout récemment dans le cas de
ces deux jeunes mineurs qui ont été tués
tout récemment et il n'y a pas
d'histoire de drogue il n'y a pas de
sommes d'argent en jeu il n'y a qu'une
violence entre bandes une violence
gratuite et stupide et moi je ne peux
pas ne pas y voir comme professeur le
résultat de la faillite de notre
éducation nationale d'une crise il
cative très profonde je l'avais dit dès
les déshérités le livre que j'ai publié
en 2014 je ne veux pas le citer pour
faire de la promotion mais mais
simplement pour dire qu'au fond c'est le
point de départ de mon engagement en
2014 quand j'ai quand j'ai commencé par
dons en 2009 ma première rentrée dans un
lycée de zones urbaines sensibles
un jeune a été tué devant la porte du
lycée à coups de tournevis quinze jours
après la rentrée et je vois dans cette
mort au pied d'un lycée le signe de
l'échec de l'école là où la culture
n'est plus transmise il ne faut pas
s'étonner de voir ressurgir le contraire
de la culture c'est à dire une forme de
barbarie souvent dans votre famille
politique c'est la réponse pénale qui
est mise en avant où la répression
vous êtes un peu une voix isolée au fond
dans un chez les républicains sur cette
question de l'éducation
non je ne crois pas d'abord il faut pas
opposer les deux je pense qu'il ya
évidemment le le psychiatre maurice
berger qui est un spécialiste de la
psychologie des jeunes l'a dit mieux que
moi
la réponse pénale fait partie de la
dimension pédagogique il faut que pour
toutes atteintes aux biens pour toutes
atteintes aux personnes il est
systématiquement une sanction parce que
si ça n'est pas le cas alors cela crée
un sentiment d'impunité qui produit de
fait cette violence désinhibé donc il
faut pas opposer un système pénal
efficace et de ce point de vue il faut
donner à la justice les moyens de faire
son travail de faire son travail de
manière rapide de faire son travail en
particulier en matière de justice des
mineurs d'une manière qui soit
transparente et qu'ils soient du coup
véritablement éducative mais bien sûr il
y à aussi en amont le signe dans cette
violence d'une faillite de l'éducation
parce que je ne dis pas que quelqu'un
qui est éduqué quelqu'un qui est cultivé
ne peut pas faire de mal les gens les
plus cultivés du monde ont parfois
étaient des et les peuples les
plus cultivés du monde ont parfois été
barbare ce que je dis ça n'est pas que
la culture empêche toujours l'homme
d'être inhumain mais que l'inculture
empêche toujours les hommes d'être
complètement humains et ce qui se joue
dans cette violence gratuite que nous
voyons monter aujourd'hui c'est la
pauvreté du langage c'est la pauvreté
des relations humaines créé par cet
effondrement de la culture c'est le fait
que lorsque les cadres n'existe plus les
cadres éthiques et moraux fondamentaux
lorsqu'ils n'ont pas été posées par
l'éducation et il ya quelque chose qui
évidemment doit interroger les familles
aussi
et notre rapport aux familles lorsque
tout cela n'est pas stabilisé alors nous
ne pouvons pas encore une fois éviter
que la violence soit partout évidemment
la réponse pénale est important mais on
ne mettra pas un policier derrière
l'épaule de chaque français est donc ce
qui a été ratée dans l'éducation sera
très difficile à rattraper par le
système pénal par le système judiciaire
je pense qu'on ne peut pas souhaiter une
société de surveillance généralisée
on ne peut que souhaiter que l'éducation
cultive en nous le désir d'une vie
vie d'une vie dans la civilité qui est
fondamentalement la condition de toute
vie en société et merci beaucoup merci
françois xavier mais la vie était ce
matin merci marcelo ont regardé ce
parisien aujourd'hui en france deux
titres nicolas sarkozy le coup dur et
puis que 8,19 macron cette phrase il
faut obtenir encore quatre à six
semaines
merci beaucoup monsieur des trognons pas
de suite aux cas merci à blois la
mutuelle nationale t
[Musique]